we're here billy had a bit of a hiccup
um it was a big hiccup you were supposed
to come on our podcast and you switching
[ __ ] up that was the hiccup
and ain't that confusing that's not
right exactly right let's get let's go
i have the screen i have the
conversation in the dms literally i said
come on little podcast
i'll give you a fair shake i said nope
okay this is ridiculous we're gonna bore
people i said i'd rather live stream it
it turned into this big thing your
assistant agrees
i told you i told you you could live
stream it but live stream the podcast
but then here we are we're doing some
other [ __ ] which is fine
but again that's not what we agreed to
and it is what it is
that's not true i sent your assistant in
a link
not true it is
let's talk about the beginning of this
whole conversation which was you
calling me out right at the beginning of
this conversation
was the beginning of this conversation
me calling you out
or you posting videos about i didn't
even know you existed
you posting videos about me and then me
responding to your nonsense which one
was it just so we could get the [ __ ]
straight
uh what did i say about you did you
watch the video yeah you had two you had
two videos my team tells me yeah i saw
like i saw a little bit of one which is
fine whatever
but like you were the one that posted
about us
and then i responded but again second
time you're lying about the setup
now you're lying about how the
communication came up absolutely no no
no no no no no no no i didn't
i didn't call you i just saw you
did i say should i say anybody know this
[ __ ] boy
he made an entire vic tear down
other people i said did i just tell you
i don't know
me to read it for you does anybody know
this [ __ ] boy
in response to the videos you made about
me
i did not know you existed right you
made me you're
you're saying you're saying i'm trying
to hurt people you didn't even watch my
videos hold up i didn't even say
anything
is this true is this true or not did you
make videos about me
i talked about you i talked i talked
about your channel
as a pattern of people retiring right
that's that okay i understand but did
you talk about me
two different times before i posted that
because you're trying to take things out
of context in informal a different way
did that happen yes or no what i'm
trying to
well look at the dates you posted the
[ __ ] this is the third line we just
started billy
bailey bailey bailey billy billy billy
we got we got we gotta come to a reset
here we gotta come to a reset
we gotta come to a reset here i'm trying
to bring people
up to speed okay let let me give the
full content let me give everything
right but if you give it
again let me get let me give let me get
let me get full contact
i'm gonna cut you off until you tell the
truth billy let's
let's get let's get let's give it let's
give full context can i do that thank
you
appreciate that give the full context
i'm going to interject right
okay so do you know what my show is i
guess you
you don't do do you
do you know my channel do you have
contacts no i'm just asking you
generally just so i before i start do
you know what my show is
i'm ready for you to give content yeah
so i talk about sort of this
uh business space whatever all this
stuff right
so i was talking about you know some of
these guys who are
you know doing like little fake
retirement things i kind of jabbed about
you a little bit
but seriously it was kind of light stuff
i mean there's nothing serious it was i
agree now watch this i agree with you it
was like
so uh good i'm glad we agree so uh the
second thing i think i said was i was
like i
made a video called cringe marketing
that's far where i was talking about
multiple marketing
pieces but then i talked about yours i
was like actually it's pretty
interesting right
okay so then we see
so now we are so now we are now we are
two times you're talking about me at
this point
before this post so what i said stands
true again
i'm gonna keep it real with you i'm not
even here to like you know embarrass all
that stuff i'm i'm here to keep it
honest but that's how the conversation
is we're fine we're fine
yes anybody know this [ __ ] why he made
an entire youtube channel dedicated to
territory
with the passion that when i wrote it
that wasn't the passion of when i wrote
it when i wrote this [ __ ] it was funny
you making this seem lame this [ __ ] was
funny would you like me to read it for
you
sure all right scroll up so i can see it
so we can really get the emphasis in the
energy
of how i wrote it i feel like you you're
[ __ ] my poetry up okay
it says does anybody know this [ __ ] boy
okay you can continue go ahead uh main
entire youtube channel dedicated to
tearing down other people says a bunch
of [ __ ] i'd never say to other people's
faces
so with that i'd like to say because you
said that i would
never say this to your face i would like
to say what i said about you
to your face you realize you are behind
a computer screen
only an internet troll would literally
think you're saying this to my face
i can find it to you in person i can
guarantee you
anything that you don't think i tell you
[ __ ] billy billy
oh i'd love to tell you this i'd love
for you to be in this room right now so
i can tell you
your face that your marketing is cringe
i will
fly you to my [ __ ] office in san
diego so i can say your marketing is
crazy
so you're more than your
your marketing your retirement it's
cringe
bro your existence is [ __ ] cringe you
how do you actually i got a question for
you how do you get paid real quick
how do you get paid how do you get paid
from youtube how do you get paid
what are you talking about like the
basics of youtube
do you get paid from youtube
do you get paid from youtube for your
videos yeah
that's how ads work exactly so you
[ __ ] make videos
talking [ __ ] about other people so you
can make more money
who the
[Music]
75
watched a single one of my videos you
haven't watched a single one of my
videos
robbing desperate kids you're robbing
desperate kids
out of millions of dollars and you're
flexing on the internet about it
you're putting pictures in front of the
lambos you're flexing on the internet
about it
and then you're like hey dude look what
a cool business guy i am
i call it out you go uh he's a hater
he's just talking [ __ ] on the internet
okay
so good now you've said your piece i'm a
con then
i'm robbing kids not the money can you
give me some examples hey hey hey hey
first
first first first verse [ __ ] example
of anything you said
hey hey hey
was it the awards for san diego's best
places to work
which one was it was it the [ __ ]
business are we are we all talking about
a relevant thing
are we all talking about relevant things
can i tell you sort of my biggest
because can i tell you my biggest
problem with you
no okay i guess you didn't come on the
live stream to talk
you came to blow out everyone's ears
with your mic let me let me talk let me
talk to you for a second
listen listen listen you called me fake
news in your show
right correct you call me fake news in
your show correct facts
then you say okay you assume what i'm
saying
right after not watching my video let me
say this
when i was talking a second ago you said
you said you make your money by just
talking trash
i responded to that listen listen one
second let me let me finish let me
finish this you can go off
let me finish and then you can go up let
me finish and then
let me finish and then you can go off
let me finish in the uk off okay
one second so i said so the the people
that i'm talking
about the people that you're talking
about are like people like
dan lok people like tai lopez
people like kevin david have you ever
i've called them
i i've taken uh ty lopez's course have
you met ty or dan
no i know them both right have you ever
had a conversation with them
no no i i know because i've heard you
suck up to them on podcasts
i've heard you i've heard you i've heard
you say i've heard from their students
who've lost tens of thousands of dollars
from them
while they flex in their mansions and
you go on their podcast going
wow such a big fan ty i'm such a big fan
dan
look this is guys hey this is crazy i'm
happy to have dan on my podcast
i'm i'm happy to have them on the live
stream i'm happy to have ty on a live
stream they won't come on i
invited i invited dan
what's your name stephen what is it
steven steven
you never even had a conversation with
both of them
but you sit here and call themselves
they won't go on a conversation with me
had
the victims of their courses on my show
do you think they'd have a conversation
with me but have the victors
of their successes you had the victims
quote unquote your words
have you had tours yeah like a a teacher
who's
twenty thousand dollars lost twenty six
thousand dollars with dan lok have you
had
thousands of the success stories though
this is my thing with you and let me
tell you i actually because i
wanna be clear here for your audience
yeah i don't actually knock everything
you do i think what you do to an extent
is important because there is a lot of
[ __ ] out there and a lot of people
are getting [ __ ] over
where it becomes where are the people
voicing that
where are the people let me finish but
where it becomes
problematic is the fact that you don't
give
both sides so you say something about
someone never have having a conversation
with them
only taking the quote-unquote victims
and not talking to the people who have
had successes
so you are worse than cnn fox and
[ __ ] tmz
that's poison that's dangerous that's
cancerous
please can i say something first of all
it's not true that i've never talked to
these guys
talk to a lot of them talk to a lot of
them talk to a lot of them sasha people
like john
talk to people like evan luther talk to
people like
caleb maddox okay i want to talk to
people
i'm happy to talk to you and like you
said it look was it that hard to get a
conversation with me
no it honestly wasn't you just have to
dm me on instagram you'll get a
conversation right away
can i be honest with you yeah yeah the
reason why i had a conversation with you
because what you said is true in the
beginning
you said what you said about me wasn't
bad honestly i was not offended like
people say [ __ ] like that that didn't
bother me you really didn't
it was when i started scrolling through
the channel and i realized this is like
a pattern
it wasn't even interjection i'm cool
like people have moments you make a
[ __ ] video your content creator
you have an opinion that's one thing but
i was like bruh when you have
multiple and several and you're doing
this i'm like let's
talk about let's talk about some of
these videos that's that's why
i posted that because i was upset i'm
like nobody should make
money tearing other people down i like
you calling them out have a conversation
with them
like raise questions that is [ __ ]
healthy but when you're just talking
[ __ ] about people you discourage them
and i got audio clips for days that we
can [ __ ] bump over here i'll put it
on my package yeah yeah
listen i got audio clips of you for days
saying things like
why should someone ever charge
information that's more than the price
of a book
why shouldn't anyone do anyone
advertising is a scam
you know how much i didn't [ __ ] hold
on do you know what you have to record
it i got to record it
out of context turn that [ __ ] up out of
context video
anyone advertising is a scam that's what
i said i never said that
go to his [ __ ] [ __ ] but he said
it he said any ad hold on i got my snack
we're going to play the joint right here
for your people man
he said there's something along the
lines i'm paraphrasing but we hit a
quote so
no the advertising [ __ ] johnny played
the one he was talking about anyone
who's out
while he pulls that up while he pulls
that up so you so you talk
so first of all first of all johnny play
the clip johnny just give him a second
man let's breathe you out here rushing
stuff i got time i'm good you bring in
energy you're bringing energy to this
conversation
because i you know like i think there's
some like i said i'm not against
you i think you genuinely had
in the past a good intent i think at the
world and became something else
when you saw that can you look can you
look at my recent videos please i don't
think you've paid attention to my recent
videos
hey hey real quick hey hey billy billy
you haven't watched
more than three of my videos and i can
tell look this is about a hedge fund
manager
this is about advertising this is about
a straight-up bitcoin scam where
somebody is stealing money
straight up stealing like straight like
not not a question straight up stealing
this is about this is about a uh
somebody who's making it all youtube
awesome
what i'm saying is you're accusing me of
like all you do is talk trash
that's not true you don't know what my
content is
and you're accusing me hold on this is
an important point you're accusing me of
being fake news and cnn and fox news and
you said yeah you got to do your
research before talking
but you come into this conversation so
heated but you don't know what i do
it's clear to me i came in i have 17
audio clips of you saying reckless [ __ ]
that actually hurts people instead of
tell me what they are
let's go through because but because we
want a new thing it's there can you play
the [ __ ] we're going to do the
podcast
don't worry we're going to do the
podcast it's fine
not that [ __ ] he literally said the
advertising thing just so we're doing it
he can't find it so we're talking about
marketing here we're talking about
batted financial advice on tick tock
because people are learning
you're telling me i'm lying every time
you said i've been lying i've showed you
that you were lying
the [ __ ] clip he says that
basically anyone [ __ ]
advertising is a scam we just listened
to it [ __ ] four seconds ago find the
joint we'll circle back to it give
johnny time to find that
but that's fine but anyways going back
to what you're saying what you're what
you're saying i'm saying against you
is that all you do is talk trash right
like
i i agree that is not true like you got
me hyped like i'm i'm making a point of
being facetious like
but nonetheless the fact that it's a
part of your portfolio
it's a bulk and that's how you make
money bruh
like some of your most watched videos
aren't talking about
with one thing let's start with one
thing go ahead how my career
how my career started why i started
coffees well i think that's an important
i have your clip of your first video
you said i want to do coffee and do
youtubers and find out interesting
things
you have this genuine curiosity so i
want to know when does [ __ ] go south
when did you feel yourself here it is
they're talking about everything
listen listen this is your first video
right this is your first video okay
you're a fan of other youtubers keep
going yeah i still am a fan
is this supposed to be like a barbara
walters moment like a gotcha
that's their idea all right kill that
such a nice kid you're just such a nice
kid i'm like i like that kid
i'm rooting for that kid how can i
support that kid and they just saying
something
i have questions for you because i
genuinely want to know like who you are
you own people your name is like
were you bullied in school like when did
it switch and
like what what were you like can i
explain if that's a genuine question
i'll
genuinely answer okay okay guys let's go
let's take this podcast or let's take
this live stream
let's find it we listen let's find a
good way to bring it down to a real
place okay because i do think we both
want to get to a real place here
okay listen so when i started this
channel
youtube channel coffee break is doing
well okay
400 000 subscribers i'm doing fine with
it
i'm a little i'm looking at the
educational system on youtube and i
don't like how it incentivizes clickbait
at the same time i'm interested in
pursuing a more personality-centered
brand or like a channel real quick right
you
did that but you don't like that it
incentivizes clickbait
you know we could both agree your whole
channel is clickbait like come on now
like you can say that but all right but
that's look at your titles i mean the
whole thing your thumbnails
the 5 million super bowl ad tier list we
talk about the super bowl hedge fund
manager breaks down
gamestop we talk about that what i'm
talking about though no but i very i
very honestly shifted towards uh
entertainment of course
bro like yeah that's what i'm saying so
don't like hate on this clickbait [ __ ]
no i'm not i'm just tell i'm just
telling you where i was you asked me how
i got started whatever
and so i decided okay uh you know i'm
gonna move away from coffee break for
now i'm gonna go back to it
really i never made a decision to stop
coffee break but i
noticed this sort of epidemic on youtube
of these core sellers and look at
they're all fake scams
i didn't call you a fake guru that's the
funny thing you came up with so much
i didn't call you a fake guru and then
you go show me where i called you i
didn't call you a cop
that's what i find amazing about this
conversation this is this is this is the
thing is you you didn't call me those
things
that's why i think it's important i want
to let everybody know why i'm on here it
wasn't about me what made me nothing can
hurt me like what you said about me like
my [ __ ] resume procedure
it was others because can i give you a
flip can i give you a flip you didn't i
agreed with that three times
this is the perspective i want to give
you though and this is important for
everybody
is when you create videos like this
and the way you do it without reporting
both sides which is my thing not the
fact that you comment on them
whatever but not reporting both sides my
fear is so i got 130 000
students in 75 countries a lot of them
have solid businesses that genuinely
help people
and they get terrified to go on video
because they're afraid somebody will say
something mean to them so then i find
you and it triggered me because i'm like
you're the person stopping somebody from
getting out the dope message
that's not true because you report one
side in front of you you give people who
are my clients you keep people talking
to you very generically
so let me ask you this do you not see
how you
doing videos like that can negatively
impact somebody
i think that the people that i'm
helping getting out of this toxic
self-help industry saying that you need
to spend two thousand dollars to make it
in this world
is helping people now now
let me say the other side of that let me
say that i didn't answer my question
hold on pause right there
let's just go one piece at a time sure
so like when you mention that even that
to me is funny
you hate on someone that wants to invest
two thousand dollars into themselves
but have you ever been told do you have
you ever owned a business bro
buddy okay have you just yes or no i'm
looking yesterday
i'm not going to business like what kind
of business like a group of questions
that you pay taxes on any [ __ ]
business anything
yeah if you consider this a business
which i kind of more consider it like
just a show but yeah it's like it's a
business though because you make a
profit from it
at the end of the year do you pay taxes
at the end of the year yeah
this is a business bro so this is your
first i mean i guess it's a business in
the way the same way literally any show
is
i think what you're trying to say i
think what you're trying to say i'm
telling you what i'm trying to say
and it's the fact that you're giving
advice even if your advice is to not
[ __ ] with somebody else
you're giving advice and you ain't got a
[ __ ] business you're a scam
what a big scam i'm giving advice
i'm telling you don't listen to these
fraudsters on the internet who doesn't
have a business is telling you who to
listen to
christ your stock picks and you're
[ __ ] cryptic i'm not
you're saying i'm giving advice i'm
telling you i'm telling you not to take
these idiots advice don't take my advice
i do i give advice do i tell people how
to live their life do i sell a course
on how to live their life no i do not
because i have a question before you i
got a question for you and this is this
is
let's talk about ridiculous you have
created a successful youtube channel
regardless if i i think it's out of
integrity and i don't think it's right
but you have so i want to credit you for
that
and i also want to credit you because i
know that's hard as [ __ ] but i would
willing to be
to bet that you made so many damn
mistakes on the come up you know i mean
you made so many errors so if you
created a course
to help people start their youtube
channel the right way because there's a
lot of misinformation out there on the
internet as we both know
you don't think that'd be beneficial
absolutely not this is where this is
where you and i fundamentally disagree
you're correct correct don't explain hey
tell me how i'll explain i'll actually
i will explain i'm listening educational
self-help industries such crap because
of this key fact
the majority of learning is through
experience
it's through mistakes if i hadn't made
those
first 100 bomber videos i would not be
the youtuber
i am today let me give you a question
who's not that successful his name is
warren buffett
you can learn from your own mistakes or
you can learn from somebody else's
who the [ __ ] is the genius i can't
finish myself
listen yeah because that's why warren
buffett is selling a course
go buy warren buffett's course reckless
[ __ ] if warren buffett's selling of
course go by warren buffett's course but
he doesn't
if warren buffett was [ __ ] born in
anything
instead we have kevin david plagiarizing
people claire
watch this yo hey i agree with that
right so we're not sure we're not
understanding
why are you demonizing people for
selling their knowledge
which took them decades and millions and
hundreds of thousand dollars to come up
with like why should somebody give up
their hard work
their education their experiences for
[ __ ] free
this is [ __ ] america i don't
[ __ ] out of here
i don't demonize people for selling
their education
you just when somebody no no listen
listen to me for one second
when somebody sells their education and
they wrap it around
a pretty little dream that's not gonna
happen for people
because the way you become a successful
piano player hey remind remind me to
never buy a [ __ ] mindset course from
you
listen to what the [ __ ] you just said
when when you're prepping it about don't
tell them
if you sell a dream that's never gonna
happen for people this is who y'all
follow what you call them the
coffeezilla gang or army
this is your dude the guy who's like
you're probably talking about
i know you haven't watched the show and
you're talking a lot of trash i'm trying
to figure out the people following you
who can i but you keep
interrupting me before i finish what i'm
gonna say and so it's like it's hard for
you to hear if you want
continue on but you just say so much
reckless [ __ ] and you want to go on a
stream of reckless [ __ ] and it's
dangerous
so i'm like let's go piece by piece i
want to let you talk but i don't want
you to run on
but not talking about you interrupt me
in the middle of every sentence
i apologize go ahead okay so where were
we we were talking about
uh selling selling education right so i
have no problem with
selling education right the problem is
is that it's wrapped up what do all
these people teach
they teach wrap up your education
alongside what they really want which is
they want wealth so you wrap up this
like thing of like oh
learn facebook ads if it was just learn
a hard skill i don't have a problem with
that
right the truth is no one's gonna buy
learn a hard skill for two thousand
dollars
unless you wrap it in some kind of
wealthy well generally speaking i'm
talking about the general case that i
talk about
there's a lot of [ __ ] i'll give you
that right and you've said the same
thing you made a bunch of instagram
posts about it
and you come to me and basically my the
vibe i'm getting from you
is that i do a thing but i do it in the
wrong way a way you don't approve of
now let me ask you what's the mechanism
for this industry to self-correct
what's this mechanism for the industry
to self-correct if not for someone like
me
real quick i just want to say i do
approve of some of the things you do i
don't want to come up here and seem like
i'm just hating on you because i don't
want to [ __ ]
knock you down i want to knock down the
tactics of knocking others down to get
ahead
that's my main shift right now but i do
think you had
at some point a genuine purpose and i do
think calling out things are great
it's just if you if ever we just came
out of it just listen to listen to me
just
we just came out of an election year
right you saw this country
more divided than it's ever been in some
time
and the number one culprit was quote
unquote the news right
you go to cnn it tells you one thing you
go to fox tells you another thing but
you know what both of them
agree on is they never tell the other
[ __ ] side and it's dirty
they never give anybody else credit and
that is what concerned me about you so
you tell these stories but you give him
one side i'm saying
well but i don't think that's true i
think that's a biased perspective
what i do now what i do now let me let
me be honest i think i've become
better with time not worse i recently
started this thing called webinar
wednesdays where rather than just talk
about advertising which i used to rip
into
i take the course i review the course
i take i take the module i like that i
go through it i i don't just talk about
the advertising i go through the course
i judge the course
on the content right i interview experts
i
interview people real business owners oh
it's a series we called real jobs we're
still trying to get more people to go
join that
i do things i talk about great
advertising because i don't want the
whole thing to just be about bad
advertising
i have made a conservative effort to
make this channel
not just a negative place and i'm moving
in that
direction but i i don't know i feel like
i feel like if your perspective is like
oh you're doing the right thing but in
the wrong way
my question is then show me the guys do
who's doing the right thing because i
don't see no offense anyone in the
industry like
sort of i consider myself sort of an
outsider and i think my role as an
outsider is important
because when i say this is a scam you
know that i'm not going to go hey
now take my course which is so common
there's very many uh
i think it is coming yeah so it's like
people go everything's a scam
except for me right i don't do that i
don't have that game
i say look i think this guy's a scam i
think this guy's maybe a little over the
top whatever
but then at the end of the day i don't
have something to sell you so
i think that that would be my thing is
like well one you are getting paid off
of it so
that's that but i think my thing is not
in a way that hurts if they've changed
at the bottom
like that
great point you say not the people that
hurts the people on the bottom
you scaring away people from investing
in themselves and taking a [ __ ] leap
of faith
let me tell you it hurts [ __ ] people
at the bottom
you're wrong you're wrong this is
because i'll tell you my expertise this
is what i've been doing for 12 years man
and i had a real company agency working
with some of the largest franchises in
the world i didn't touch education until
that was my [ __ ]
right like i had my skill set et cetera
that's where it came in
but dude you don't understand i see i
have these conversations with real small
business owners
they're so deathly afraid to take a risk
to take a leap because we're [ __ ]
poisoned
like take my grandmother for example
rest in peace my grandmother's whole
thing was billie jean
don't [ __ ] uh uh start your own
business
don't don't start your own business
until you have a job for 30 years you
got all this experience et cetera
my grandmother never owned a [ __ ]
business why grandma i love you why the
[ __ ] are you giving me business advice
i wouldn't be where i am today at 32 if
i would have listened to grandparents
you got people out here listening to
their parents for [ __ ] financial
advice and they're broke
you got people out here listening at
coffeezilla for financial advice i don't
give financial advice
i don't give financial advice you
telling people what not to do is still
advice my friend
it's still like the people i'm telling
them the people
that became a wealth advisor yesterday
that aren't registered brokers
that have absolutely no experience in
the business and yesterday
started up and today they're making two
million dollars off the backs of a bunch
of
broke desperate kids i i think now now
in even that part the last one i'm with
you as far as calling [ __ ] out but then
you said
on the backs of broke desperate kids how
do you know who their customers are
actually because insiders have come to
me i mean i'm not going to i'm not going
to name names because this is
this is comprehensive but like you don't
you don't know what i want to say hold
on one second
one second they shared me they shared
with me like sales reports
i saw that this one company this was a
while back like probably
10 months ago this company was doing uh
i think it was 10 million
i think it's been a while i think it was
like 4 million a month or something like
trying to clip
did you find the clip literally it was
there was only six that we played in the
very beginning we put them in the
[ __ ] intro
um for four million and basically the
idea is is i knew the fact i knew it
they they told me the person came to me
because they said i don't like what
these people are doing it's an anomaly
but listen for a second but listen for a
second they said we were telling people
who couldn't afford the course to go get
a personal loan
to take out the rest of the money to
invest in themselves
and get it you're talking you talk you
talk about college you're talking about
college which one
yell stuff no we're talking about we're
talking about courses oh oh
you said you you wanted people to borrow
money and get into serious debt and then
go learn something make money 30 years
later oh you said if you want to talk
about if you want to talk about how
education is especially
oh okay do you want to talk about that
because we can i have a whole thing
about that
i don't know we need to have a whole
thing about it but i think we're in
green set the logic you just said is
literally the logic that [ __ ]
employs doctors that's their program
that they follow you know what's the
promise of hold on let me finish you
know what the promise of attorneys and
[ __ ]
medical professionals is go into debt
300
000 it will take you 30 years to pay it
back
you won't even start making till 11
years later
and then 11 years later you get a job
that will make you six figures and
you'll still be enslaved in debt
that [ __ ] right there and you're worried
about somebody investing two thousand
bucks
to to take advantage and learn from
someone who invested in
hours and hours or whatever the [ __ ] but
you know what i'm saying like bro like
what why are you hating on someone
getting ahead and taking a risk
i'll take my i'll take my personal [ __ ]
right like you know
you know how you learn the game of
advertising the thing that you hate on a
lot
i learned the game of advertising
because i was one of those advertising i
just don't like what it's done the way
it's done with
the direct response guru model there is
but at the same time bro i came up
through buying the [ __ ] that you're
[ __ ] shying people away from there
would be no billing
my impact on the 130 000 students i
would not have
i wouldn't be able to do any of those
things you know what i'm saying and then
you talk about like
you know you said something i don't
remember what it is because this is your
setup so we don't have a lot of our [ __ ]
but you said something about influencers
and how they're all
fake and like that whole [ __ ] it's never
real
and and and i'll play it on my [ __ ] so
that way everyone knows i'm not just
pulling [ __ ] on my ass
but like i mean what is that all about
right because and by the way
there are some [ __ ] [ __ ]
influencers but when you
[ __ ] throw this blanket on on a on a
whole
don't think i mean i can't i'm not going
to tell you i didn't say that because
you might have it
johnny yeah i like i can't i can't talk
to you about
this thing when i don't know what i said
uh i don't know what you said about
influencers all being fake because i'm
pretty sure that's what it is
uh well i'll give you my opinion right
now there are a lot of influencers are
fake are you talking about like gurus
specifically
no this is you what you said you said oh
go
i don't remember what i said look listen
yeah
again since i make [ __ ] up i get i get
can you just repeat it for the for the
class because we can't hear it
we can't hear it that well you can have
to repeat it for everybody
who's running right now last one
i can't last
them because one keeps running ads right
now they're fake
it said people running ads yeah you
heard it oh
sure i think that was that from graham
stephen the graham stefan video yeah i
don't know i don't [ __ ] with it because
yes that's
just okay let's give the context to that
let's give the context because context
this is the thing is nobody always is
not important you were saying that
you're
you're the one saying at the beginning
of this that i had to have context text
is important but when you do things like
this as a leader and a thought leader
and someone with subscribers
people don't always hear that [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying sure hope i'm not a
thought leader billy
i told you i'm not giving advice i'm
just talking
listen hold on so let's talk about this
this gram stuff
i hope no one follows your thoughts but
you are what you are regardless if i
agree with you
whatever i'm not going to charge you for
it i guess you can get it for free
so we talked about so graham stefan
graham stefan's video
was basically about how that's another
kid who does this [ __ ] right
he does the [ __ ] no no no no that's me
okay no no okay
graham stefan's like one of these
personal finance guys right and he said
he said there's so many
uh they're sorry there's only a few
fly-by-night
snake oil salesmen most of them are
legit
and in that video i was responding to
that and i said no that's actually
not true graham it's actually the
reverse there's only a few people
that if it were me i would be listening
to
and most of them are fly by night snake
oil salesmen
now i would be shocked if you disagreed
with that statement right there
i would say a lot of them are but i
wouldn't say words like most men like i
don't know i would never make the
statement because i don't know most
you know what i'm saying i keep to my
like [ __ ] like i don't know most but is
that out there should people be aware
100
like i mean this is your instagram post
there's a lot of fraud and scams
mostly as in most you said the word most
broke business coaches making a career
teaching something they never
accomplished
so you do agree with me you agreed with
me last year
listen listen listen listen listen
a couple of things number one
when your entire channel is dedicated
not my
channel when you when you have
consistent how long's your channel been
existence
uh like two years ago i started it and
by the way
this is not my dream of like what i'm
going to do
there's a difference between all and
most mind you sure mind you but
when you come on and you consider
[ __ ] selling your information
buying courses and people being [ __ ]
idiots for all this
for investing into themselves what
[ __ ] good are you doing
um i'm saving people from this
cycle in the self-help space of thinking
that there's one per cycle of healthcare
of
no cycle of helping themselves listen
listen okay okay i've tried look i just
talked to a guy the other day we're
about to release it this guy who he's
ten thousand dollars in the hole and we
asked him how much money have you made
he's
said none i've just got to keep spending
that was his whole point
he sounds like every doctor buddy look
you can make fun of education all
you want they have proven that over time
you make more money
with a college degree you make more
money so you can keep saying
300. listen you can keep saying 300.
keep saying it's a scam to go to school
but they make more money on average and
listen when you're talking to
masterpieces
look when you're talking to masses of
people do you think it's a good idea to
recommend people go to uh to go to l.a
what to be an actor to be an actor no
it's a bad idea
why because most people don't become
actors right bro let me tell you what's
happening now
i don't want to pour into you like this
but and i'm not in a bad way
i don't know what you missed or didn't
accomplish in your life
but you projecting what you didn't get
onto someone else
is the most [ __ ] dangerous thing you
can do and i'm not
i'm not hating and listen to me because
when i say that i don't mean that in a
bullish like
like just trying to pick [ __ ] way i'm
letting you know dude that is scary
that in fact you just said that was so
much conviction i'm i'm the opposite if
you're watching me i want you to go
[ __ ] chase it
in la if you want to be an actor and
actress and you think that's gonna get
your head
i want you to do it i want you to invest
yourself you're talking about you're
talking about
me spitting dis dangerous information
and then you're going oh yeah everyone
that went to be a [ __ ] youtuber how
unrealistic is that
my god yeah i got you there bro what are
you
talking about lisa i think you're going
to remove this turn this [ __ ]
what are you talking about
i don't even know where you're going
with this i'm confused now are you
playing some clip right now we can't
hear i i i we are playing a clip
of you saying that you're not even a web
developer you studied chemical
engineering
i did yeah well can i can i bring up
something you that example of going to
la
is unrealistic and ridiculous as someone
saying i'm going to drop out of being a
chemical major
and be coming
masses of people right and we're talking
about how to better yourself
how to do better in life you have to set
yourself up for success right you have
to set yourself up don't
don't don't that's why that's why i went
to chemical engineering
that's why i became a chemical engineer
and then i was like i also want to chase
my dream
but i have something to fall back on
nice it's a nice degree
don't definitely don't don't don't ever
put your limitations on somebody else
bro i'm gonna tell you honestly you
don't believe in statistics you don't
believe in statistics
you don't believe in market reality you
believe in this weird world
okay hey hey ninety percent of
businesses will fail between the over
the span of 10 or 12 years
does that mean they shouldn't try
no what are you talking about but you
wouldn't lie to them about their chances
right
i'm not listening absolutely i'm not
telling people hey
never go to la what i'm saying is your
odds are low and if you're gonna
recommend it you honestly believe i
honestly believe
you're gonna delete this video after
because you are getting murdered
like this this is not it's not this is
not going good for you
in any capacity like i feel the opposite
then you should re-watch the [ __ ] out of
this because i'm telling you man
you can i guarantee your own followers
are like damn what the [ __ ] we've been
doing oh see
hey here's what i'll do too i'm going to
do one you want better buddy and i'm not
even going to profit off this but
they're probably going to end up buying
more of my [ __ ] later if they want you
don't have to give it away
i have maybe i'll clip this out no
thanks please
come on what are you pitching i want to
give them for free am i [ __ ] 30
30 days of course and something like
he's getting his marketing uh funnel
oh god forbid you learn something new
that will help you hey
you can get salt you can get sold more
crap keep it keep it away
oh my god bro i'm going to tell you i
figured you out this is all i want
can i say can i say this you you are a
hurt individual that's looking to hurt
other people you know what
i'm saying about you i'm i'm living i'm
living my dream what are you talking
about
hey if someone told you you better not
[ __ ] drop out of chemical engineering
school
because that youtube stuff will never
work out you would hate this
[ __ ] moving to l.a
somebody tried to profit off of me while
i was grinding
and robbed me of my dream because i was
too busy trying to buy
crappy courses like your chemical
engineering school
like they did your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you better wake the [ __ ] up oh
you're so out to like how much that did
you get how much debt did you go into
for that how much debt you going to for
that i had scholarships none
if you didn't have scholarships because
everyone doesn't have scholarships for
you let's look at the data
sir if you didn't have scholarships i
don't know how much money how much
money how much money how much money
would you have went into debt
uh i don't know it's like it's a it's a
public institution
no it's like 20. no so you would have
went twenty thousand dollars i would say
they robbed you
you know what i'm gonna get your back
everybody that's a scam that chemical
because you decided to drop out no hold
on let me finish and then i'll let you
go
because you decided to drop out of
chemical engineering i finished you're
not listening
you're finished they're scammed they
didn't get you a job after they're
scammed
they're scamming what are you talking
about thinking what are you talking
about i
chose not to oh my god oh you chose not
to
like some people buy a course and choose
not to do the [ __ ] work
wake up oh winners [ __ ] the 95
the 95 loss rate you guys tell
everybody oh it's not no no sorry sorry
let me not collect device let me not
collect it
the people that i'm talking about say
it's so easy some people do this yes no
most people what are you talking about
maybe maybe most maybe most
ty lopez is sitting in there with the
lambo he got the lambo right
he goes it's closer than you think ty
lopez has changed more lives than you
can even [ __ ] fathom but yet you sit
here and you [ __ ]
mock him this guy
owns he's the thought leader of our
generation
of our generation had millions of
students but here you are as a troll
with 400 000 subscribers
trying to knock somebody who's helped
millions of [ __ ] people you sound
like a clown bruh
do you sound like a [ __ ] clown when
you do this [ __ ]
sorry i should look up to tai lopez
you're right i think i think i think
we're
i think we're you know i think we're
talking in circles now
honestly i
i'll say this and then you can go i
apologize because i was mad at you
because
i was like i felt like what you were
doing was malicious i really did and
that's why
i came to that energy and that was much
so i apologize for that truly
but i but i'll tell you this i now
empathize
for you because i realize the [ __ ] you
say is literally from a place of hurt
really
and i feel bad for you and failure i
feel so bad for you right now this is
the [ __ ] up part
is you literally you think you're
winning this debate you're not just look
at the chat
bro bro you're oh my oh doug there's
nothing
in this there's nothing in this i'm
sorry guys my chat's about your
point i don't even i don't even think i
don't even think we can rewind to a
point where you said [ __ ]
anything relevant and doug here's the
thing you want to talk you want to talk
[ __ ] numbers
let's talk financial numbers if you take
a pool of the people who follow my [ __ ]
versus the people who follow your [ __ ]
who do you think is doing better
financially
the person who tells you never to
[ __ ] leave don't go to phone like in
l.a
don't take a chance right i'm sure you
make a ton of money congratulations
that's what life's all about my people
make a ton of [ __ ] money and
impact helping yeah right
my name is stephen and i make a living
talking about other people
getting youtube depending can i say
really real quick people i've never met
people i've never been in contact with
but i'll make all these you're on my
show right now
[ __ ] out of here man you know what's
really funny you know what's really
funny
it reminded me of like so you you call
me fake news but i actually think i'm
something else
okay can i tell you you can tell me
whatever so you said you said
the elon musk interview on clubhouse is
the reason people why the people need
more people like charlemagne the god wtf
right do you like charlemagne the god
this is this is this is you gotta listen
just jump on his youtube
his youtube i think he he's black guys
i'm in my studio i'm just talking to it
because uh can i tell you what you look
like right now he is he's he's nice he's
potential
essential so you like charlemagne the
god and uh
go check it out it's interesting because
actually charlemagne
how long did you prep this speech you
wrote up your clip and everything how
long did you prep this [ __ ] you feel
good
no i didn't go go get you get your punch
line go ahead you're the one who prepped
like 16
audio things i'm not gonna go tell you
oh you prepped for an interview like
that's a diss
yeah i prep to talk to you go are you
going to insult me for that
you're going to insult me for being a
chemical engineer it's embarrassing is
that what
it was that was an insult was that what
you took from that is affected
but they told everybody to
honestly i don't think this could have
gone better for me
and like you should delete this [ __ ] for
me i gotta go bro
wait you're just gonna leave what else i
mean what if i got something can i trust
i don't think you're a bad guy i i do
apologize for calling you a [ __ ] boy
because you know i i think the [ __ ] boy
is warranted if you're being malicious
um i don't think you're being malicious
i do think you're confused and you have
a long journey
and i can guarantee you this there will
be a point in your life where you would
change this mentality
of like never getting mentorship et
cetera like
i mean they said no sports [ __ ]
person ever like this is just ridiculous
like your whole i don't even know if you
believe the [ __ ] you say like when you
listen back you're like i don't really
believe that you know what i mean
no i can't look let me billy can i just
make my point
damn it you just keep interrupting me
can i make a photo make get your punch
line
all right all right all right all right
get your clip get it you said you said
on fake news right
and then at the end of our dm's you said
you better watch what you said
you better keep my name out of corrupt
something like that
i keep your name out of my mouth correct
okay
but you also love charlemagne the god
now interestingly this uh parallels a
very interesting situation with birdman
you remember that interview
i i love i love charlemagne the god so
charlemagne the god he talks about
rappers and birdman's pissed off because
he doesn't want anyone putting his name
in their mouth and he comes in angry
it's amazing you know what's amazing to
me is how so-called
millionaires are so fragile it's so
interesting y'all put yourselves out
there for millions and billions of
ye i think you said you bragged to me
that you had like billions of views or
something like that how many views do
you have
our impressions have been we've been
seeing almost 900 million times congrats
you paid for it okay great
exactly i had a question for you if i
paid for it but i made tens of millions
of dollars more did i pay for it i don't
know
you didn't matter i'll let you know if
you put yourself out for billions of
people
then why so insecure that you freaked
out when i said this question
i love this question okay here's why
because
as i said three different times during
the show i didn't come on here for me i
said what you said about me honestly
didn't definitely didn't really say
anything bad
honestly it was the [ __ ] you say about
other people and the poison that you put
out to people
no no specifically the messages you put
out to people about coaching and
investing to themselves and taking a
risk and a leap
and betting on themselves that is what
makes you
[ __ ] worse than all the rest of them
so most of these coachings you're
talking about are
courses which are repackaged
self-help from 50 years ago that they're
selling for two thousand dollars
i mean bro here's the thing if someone
buys a course that's a choice
you don't have to buy your [ __ ] like
peter you don't have to buy anything and
you're going to be exactly where you're
in life and that's how you roll
but i don't believe that i believe you
study other people and that's why you
ask someone like myself or other people
to come in
you learn a lot you're a student of the
game and you're picking [ __ ] up all the
time
problem is with so much information the
barrier to entry being solo on youtube
anybody can post anything
so when somebody says why don't i just
go to youtube to look up something
because you're likely going to run in
the wrong direction so
people don't go to med school on [ __ ]
youtube even though every single thing
you would like
to go to books that's why i tell them
but even even on books like nobody would
be a self-taught doctor why not
even though they can learn all this [ __ ]
at libraries why not that's a great
question it's because we have standards
right there's more than just learning
from a book you have to have
you have to have practicals you have to
go in
correct yeah do you think you're making
a point here yeah making a [ __ ] point
why do you think people get business
coaches
because you've got to have standards you
got to you're going they're going to
business coaches
that aren't business coaches that have
never owned
so do you believe that people should pay
for business coaches
if you're not a business already
established with no
if you have no cash flow and you're
trying to start a business
no you should not you look when you're
starting out
the best time to get a coach is after
you lose a bunch of money and waste a
bunch of time
tell that to any [ __ ] great tell that
to lebron tell that to [ __ ] kobe
tell that to tom brady what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you sound
dumb do you know what you're talking
about you're saying
hey the time you should pay for a 2 000
coach is when you're a beginner
basketball player
no the time you pay for a 2 000 code
even
steven can i ask you a question what if
you and i we're both out here
and i don't know how to build a house i
don't understand about building a house
i don't know if you do maybe you can
engineer
probably more likely than me right so
both of us are there we're looking to
buy a house
i hire a coach who's built a house a
thousand times you say i'm just gonna
[ __ ] look at them on youtube whose
house is gonna be built faster
and whose house would you bet your life
living in i don't
tell people to go learn from youtube
your roof is going to come down
i don't tell people to go learn from you
so where would they learn where would
they learn because i'm just going to go
find somebody with a construction
business who's super successful that's
done a thousand times and i'm going to
go in debt to pay them to get ahead what
are you going to do just tell me what
wait wait sorry seriously recently okay
you're trying to learn how to create
construct the house from the beginning
from the beginning you and i are going
to try and learn how to build a [ __ ]
house
okay i go to school for it hold on i get
a coach that's done
how and how much money are you going to
lose going to school
yeah they use a coach i mean yeah okay
you're going to go to school and you're
going to take an undergrad degree for
two years and learn about [ __ ]
isosceles triangles and all kinds of
weird [ __ ] and i'm gonna i'm gonna pay
against a successful entrepreneur and
and how home builder
home builder who's already done it who
the [ __ ] do you think is gonna get the
result faster
you're gonna learn how to build you're
gonna learn how to build a house without
going to college
doug you're missing i'm going to learn
from someone who does it every day
correct who the [ __ ] would you bet on
i really i'm i'm i'm stunned i'm stunned
by this conversation okay hold on just
answer the question this is wild to me
just let's follow logic here
yeah yeah yeah can we agree on something
the first two years of of
a most traditional caller this is great
can i just say no no no no no no no no
no no no this is fun
but anyways the first two years of
undergrad
what kind of courses do you typically
take uh you take like generic courses
sure
yeah give me some examples uh you take
chemistry
math you take da-da-da whatever yeah
take your basics australia astrology
yeah you learn to think no you don't
learn that you don't learn astrology
that's yeah you absolutely it's it's an
elective and it is [ __ ] for sure
does not you're talking about astronomy
astronomy whatever the [ __ ] homie
astrology
i don't give a [ __ ] because you can take
the person who learned astronomy or
astrology you take the wrong courses at
school let me tell you
like hey you better [ __ ] deflect
because my point is just [ __ ] better
than yours
so you go two years listen just listen
i'm listening
two years you're taking all the [ __ ]
undergrad yeah you learn nothing
about building a home but yet you go if
i
went to the university of san diego by
that point you would now be
50 000 into debt i pay a [ __ ]
contract manager
or project whatever the [ __ ] ten
thousand dollars who does it every day
and has been in the industry for 30
years
so i can work side by side then learning
for how long i mean with dan lok that'll
get you one hour of meetings but no see
stop stop
just our situation yeah who would you
bet on in that particular case to build
your home after those two times
if you're actually talking about that
question two years who would you better
me i don't want expression i want to yes
or no i bet on the guy who went through
the proper channels to get the right
connections
to make it their way in the world so i i
agree so what would be the proper
channel
me who learned and did it for two years
with the best in the world or you who
learned about [ __ ]
astronomy or astrology you're not going
to want to hear this spot you're not
going to want to hear this bud but
all the time people are limited by their
degrees
wait pause for a second will you just
answer who the [ __ ] would you bet on me
you went to college for it but you in
your first two years you didn't even
take a class on it yet you're still an
undergrad buddy
you realize there's more do you realize
there's more to college than like taking
classes
how to think it's how to finish
something it's a
measure of somebody about how to build a
[ __ ] house
yeah they're not going to trust me
they're not going to trust that to
somebody who said
hey don't worry trust me i got a mentor
they're going to trust the guy
who knows calculus no no they're going
to trust me who knows autocad
right he knows trust me i've been
building homes for two years with the
best in the industry
it's different what it's different you
just said they're not going to try
you just you sound like dog you're
stretching you don't sound
goofy you believe what you're saying i
say something okay listen hold up hold
up can you get no
there's no [ __ ] way you actually
believe that you would pay
the person that went undergrad and did
random courses to build a home
then the person who worked with somebody
already [ __ ] does it as you
right as a beginner as the on the job
site do you know how these things work
have you worked have you worked in a job
site i did new home sales
i worked with builders jesus christ
billy i've worked with billy you make
what are you talking about how much
money do you make you know who's the
flight now is deflecting billy i got you
listen i worked with a builder i worked
with a builder i talked to these guys
i know what the guys with no degree were
doing and they weren't
managing the houses billy sorry to break
your coaching bubble
i think you're click-baiting because now
you're just like you're just defying
logic that doesn't make any sense no now
you're deflecting no no now you're
deflecting what am i
you're missing the analogy really that's
you you're so studied and you didn't
hear a [ __ ] word i said
where's your emotional intelligence
where's your intellect what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
this is really simple would you rather
work and build a house with somebody
who's done it [ __ ] for two years
or learn at a [ __ ] undergraduate
that's scamming people left and right
but you're all good with that you want
people what do you think
what do you think is the bigger what do
you think's a bigger scam uh the the uh
course industry or do you think college
is a bigger school it depends on what
you're studying
good answer what elaborate what do you
think about
a business degree as someone who did
business administration
at the university of san diego that's
where i went which was a top-ranked
business school i didn't finish my last
class
um but as somebody who went there bruh i
can [ __ ] tell you
that no contest that college is the
biggest [ __ ] legal scam in the world
period like for business for business
and entrepreneurs specifically let me be
people
for for entrepreneurs i think that
depends actually
i think it depends what you're going to
do if you want to go start a business of
the 21st century
with like coding and stuff i think it
helps to know industries i think it
totally matters to have like a scientist
you say something different there it can
help but is it the best path
uh i think look have you look up
i know you don't like statistics but
have you looked up the statistics here
because they're against you
they're like
if you look up successful people and
i've done this because somebody somebody
named the swag academy hey hold on hold
on
you look up successful people i am the
[ __ ] successful person who started
with both parents on welfare
that's the difference between me and you
you're a critic i'm a winner
winners focus on winning critics fights
i like statistics
you like your show's about me that's
what's wrong with this [ __ ] equation
bro
wait wait wait wait wait bro i mean no
offense
but relative to like truly successful
people this is crazy you're a nobody
correct correct right but that's all i'm
saying i study
statistics if you like statistics i make
more money than 99.00
something [ __ ] people on the planet if
i'm a nobody if i'm
if i'm a nobody and what the [ __ ] does
that make you we're just talking about
why does that make you if i'm a nobody
my success is nobody what does that mean
really billy you you're the one yelling
i'm the successful person
i'm the successful person no i said
statistics you like statistics i love
statistics
you're not letting me get to the point
billy you're dodging you're dodging
again
i can't let you do this i know you're
asking me you're dodging the truth
the truth is the statistics on success
the statistics on success are
that the people who are billionaires are
ninety percent
actually it's 91 percent you even want
someone to become an actor in l.a now
you're telling people to become a
[ __ ] billionaire [ __ ] off come on man
what is that what is that are you mad at
me for wanting people to make
intelligent decisions
i'm saying if you want to be an actor
know the odds know what you're stacked
up against
right no be intelligent about it don't
just yolo into it
don't just listen to everything you know
hold on you know most people who start
med school don't complete other against
you
any professional athlete ozzie against
you successful entrepreneurs
most businesses fail odds are against
you every [ __ ] thing that requires
hard work
sacrificing getting it done the odds are
against you guess what
real ones do it anyway [ __ ] like you
sit on the sideline talk about
other people you started by saying
congratulations on the successful
youtube channel
now you're taking it away from me i know
congrats on successfully your channel
that don't make you successful listen
[ __ ] billy belly belly belly bubbles
listen to people
statistics okay listen for a second jeez
you're so close-minded i got a bit i
gotta admit i'm close-minded
said i'm closed-minded can i get a
mother is this real life
i told you i told you i take people's
courses and evaluate them queue for this
content
because i'm going to run so much [ __ ]
traffic to this
it's going to be insane you want to see
reach bro i can't wait to show this
to my [ __ ] mom mom daddy i'm a
sinister dude
this guy got my give me a [ __ ] mop
the floor sound effect
give me like holy [ __ ] i don't think
i've taken down someone like this in a
long
[ __ ] time whoa you got me hyped
coffee
i drink coffee i don't even drink coffee
i'ma have a glass of coffee today that's
how you make me feel
i don't even drink coffee all right i'm
gonna chuck some money so can i get to
my statistics are you gonna
i don't know i don't know if i'm just
celebrating yet this is too good i feel
like matter of fact i should stop it
because i can
nothing what else can good i'm just
[ __ ] with you man okay
so the statistics on billionaires is
that 91 percent of them
uh 30 millionaires like 30 million or
more
what you see is as you go up the
attainment ladder of success
overwhelmingly the more educated you are
the higher chance you have of doing
better that
okay now let's talk more facts what
you're talking about describing
is one percent of a one percent of a one
[ __ ] percent class the ultimate
elitist class
what we're talking about for successful
for most people that's just making six
figures
dude so your stats that you're using are
completely speakers
something is more true the data is
changing as technology has completely
debunked and
[ __ ] that industry you're using old
stats to try and make a new point and
you sound ridiculous again
what's that do you have to get this
let's get some coffee what somebody give
this man some coffee
god damn is your argument the stats are
going to prove me right in 20 years
you seem like a
in front of me right now but they'll
prove me right in 20 years no that
doesn't work
hey keep spotting trends in hindsight
i'll keep leading on the front edge
we'll see who does better let me tell
you this let me tell you this look
let's do stats on how many people say
that their success
is due to a two thousand dollar course
let's do that
i'd love to do that from a mentor you
ask people who are successful
all those billionaires you talk about i
would bet you any amount of money that
you want
that over 90 percent will give credit to
a culture mentor that came into life and
guess what
they won't be from the [ __ ]
school now you can stick that in your
coffee and [ __ ] smoke
this is the biggest delusion dude what
what's the delusion about that
what's the delusion about that you don't
think they'll give credit to a business
coach or a mentor
listen listen they're not gonna get they
didn't meet that they didn't meet that
listen
let me qualify they didn't meet that
mentor at the beginning but you agree
but that you agree it was because of a
mentor that they all give credit to
we're on the same page there right no
i no i don't even think so i was just
look for example you wouldn't know i was
just talking hang out with successful
people bro
who are you hanging out with ty lopez
he's not man
dude bro tai lopez is a nobody in the
scheme of why are you talking about
tai and why is he a no because that's
what you're hanging out with
you're saying i talk with success who
are you talking to successfully
the people in the course industry are
all going to say
i was mentored because it benefits them
how does that how does that make you
feel when you when you call someone a
nobody
that's accomplished a lot and helped a
lot of people what does that do for you
okay let me reframe this right because
i'm not calling tai lopez
a nobody in the absence of other things
we're talking about
success you're talking about
billionaires and you accused me
of hanging not hanging out with rich
people like you do
but why isn't success the ultimate
success helping a lot of other people
become successful
like i feel like you hate on that and
it's weird what's the strength that's
not what that's not what this industry
does
this industry makes a very small amount
of people
at the top at the top successful
that's not true from selling not even in
the industry from selling courses bud
bro giving someone knowledge is not a
new business
giving someone knowledge for two
thousand dollars is a new business no
actually you're wrong no it's not
no it's not you're right it was a lot
more i mean it was called books it was
called
you get them for a few pennies and
college was cheaper back then
i liked college more back when it was
cheaper why are you fighting so
hard to hold on to this belief that is
just [ __ ] not true and reckless it's
weird
i really know your story why are you
fighting so hard so hold on to a belief
that's not true and reckless i could say
the same thing let me
let me let me let me change gears here
where where and when
like who wha did you did you invest in
some [ __ ] and get [ __ ] honestly
what happened bro i think you want me to
be some damaged dude i'm fine like you
no but i mean i'm asking honestly i'm
not i'm sorry i apologize i'm not asking
sarcastically i'm not
i'm not i'm gonna get [ __ ] over buddy
i'm not offended
but did you no like no the fact is no
i'll tell you one thing i'll tell you
the one thing that did happen i'll tell
you the one thing that did happen thank
you something
my mom when i was in high school got
cancer
and when she got cancer she was looking
for a way to solve
the problem and a bunch of charlatans
with no medical background
started pitching to her heart okay
she wanted to take their advice but
thank god
somebody talked her into doing the damn
surgery and taking her thyroid out
because of that she's still alive today
if she had just listened to all these
clin uh clickbank guys selling her
charlatan magic pills she'd be dead
so you want to see her talk to me about
how i'm damaged i'm not damaged i'm
pissed off
for what you guys do to people and i
don't mean to lump everyone together
i'm saying a majority of this industry
with no qualifications
no backgrounds say about success they're
experts in success
hey hey hey i'm giving you a hug through
the screen i get where that comes from
that makes sense to me now
like if someone's coming at my mom's
like that that's my [ __ ] moms i'd be
the same [ __ ]
so i get it i see where that comes from
and that's helpful to understand you
like that that makes sense so i
appreciate that and i'm not mad at that
right but that's what i was saying
earlier it was like look that was your
situation and i'm so
i'm sorry i have to right that's
horrible but at the same time we can't
just cast a net
and kill all hope for everybody because
of the situation
which is easy to do let me say let me
say though let me say that this is
important
that is not what launched me on this
whole i
think it is but you don't do self-help i
have a feeling as you just
yelled at me and saying that did not
affect you that probably impacted you
man like oh look
i'm i'm saying it gets me mad that gets
me mad when i think about it but i don't
often think about it
because of the fact because of the fact
it turned out well what i'm saying
hey hold on you should go get scanned by
tony robbins he's the best scammer right
now i love him he's a great
because he's scared i'm taking his kbb
course right now thank you
it's a beautiful rehash of russell
brunson actually i'm finding
god damn it's a reaction of expert
secrets and you know it is
he made 41 million dollars on a rehash
of russell brunson
and i i thought you were doing it to
actually better yourself man you were
looking come on bro
like i honestly i feel like real [ __ ] if
you hung out with me for a month you'd
be a different person not saying i'm so
great because i'm not i got all kinds of
flaws and [ __ ]
but i'm letting you know man i just i
just want to expose you i want to
introduce you to some of these people
that you're probably classifying not
probably not people you've done your
videos on or whatever but i just want to
someone who you made traditionally at a
glance classify as one thing
i want to introduce you to them so if
you ever want to come to san diego i
would love to have you and you can stay
you can stay
now my place hotel i got to trust you a
little bit more but i'll get you [ __ ]
something real nice we can come hang out
and just introduce you to people man
show you behind the scenes like because
again
my whole thing is i like the fact you
call that [ __ ] because there's
it needs to happen but not at the
expense of killing
everyone's hopes and dreams and getting
everybody to just sit in their box and
not take any risks because they're
afraid that they're going to get scammed
i don't tell people to sit in their box
go do what you want but be educated come
hang out with me in san diego listen
be informed about the decisions you're
making listen i dropped
i dropped where you live what's the deal
with you want to come fly out here
no i'm not going to i'm in touch with
you anything like that come out man in
san diego
everything's bigger than taxes baby and
tax
there's not as many covered guidelines
either y'all are uh this is true you do
have a better place
i'll hang out with you i'll bring you
under my wing because i feel like if i
can get to you
you can continue on your youtube channel
i can see what [ __ ] like 10 million
followers being a big impact
just make sure you're doing it for good
bro cause i feel like you're this close
you just gotta kill some of this other
[ __ ] that's not true
what are you talking about why this is
like a weird like oh you're
almost there jesus you're all this is
coming through his mother this is come
to jesus really
billy yeah hang out with a bunch of
charlatans how about that for a couple
of years to hang out with you don't know
who i hang out with what i'll be i'm
listening to those dan lok episodes
where you're like
dad it's so great to meet you i love
what you're doing with that you make
such great ads dad
bro does that guy he was uh he's
on the record like five years ago saying
look i'm not gonna be a part of talking
bad about somebody else we can talk
about me all day i'll take those shots
telling you
who you're hanging out with i mean i'm
just telling you who you're hanging out
with i know who i man because
i meet like i digress right let's keep
it me and you
that's fine you can have your opinions
on other people cool i just challenge
you
to [ __ ] do work on both sides if you
bring someone back on bring someone good
on if you're bringing someone for them
being against somebody
i do that billy you just don't watch the
show bruh
i'm telling you from what i have seen
and what my team breathed
you told me you watched like two
episodes bruh let me tell you
mostly okay i asked you earlier though i
said did you bring on the good side too
and you did it i asked you that
so no i mean i i don't think there's
that good of a side to paying two
thousand dollars for a court stephen
stephen it depends on what it is and
what someone's situation is right it's
not like a black and white thing
but really you're right it's been fun i
think i'm running i think i'm running
i had fun with you you know you're guys
thanks for watching today
i appreciate you thank you to everyone
uh in the chat if you want to come to
san diego you're gonna have to decide
who who won i wanna know let me tell you
who lost
hey i don't i don't know it was about
winning or losing even though i
destroyed you
i don't think it was about when you're
losing i i don't i like
yeah like anyways i appreciate you
honestly no hey i just
please just make nice things man make
[ __ ] nice things right
all right dude i i'll never say anything
that's not just about uh you know
how great dan lok is i i didn't say that
i didn't say that either
sorry great talking to you thank you for
watching
i'll see you appreciate next time later
homie
you come to san diego